يعني بخس على واحد لوحه بروح بدبر له لوحه
بخس على واحد شويه مسامير بجيب لله حدا
بده شادر معهوش بروح بدبر حالي من هان من
هنا والله بساعد الناس اللي جاي معه بنات
ومعه معهاش زلمه بدها تساوي بنسوي لهم سوي
لهم خيم ايش الله بقدرنا بنجيب لهم حطب
بنولع لهم نار زي هيك نخبز صاج يعني ايش
بنقدر نقدم لابناء شعبنا بنقدم وان شاء
الله ان شاء الله منصورين يعني بخس على
واحد لوحه بروح بدبر له لوحه بخس واحد
شويه مسامير بجيب لله حدا بده شادر معهوش
بروح بدبر حالي من هنا من هنا في ناس ود
حلال يعني بيساعدوني بيعطوني مصاري اجيب
للناس المقطوعه زي
[تصفيق]
هيك الله يهونها ان شاء الله منصورين
والله لو لاخر طفل عننا منصورين ومش حنطلع
من بلادنا لو بدنا نموت كلنا مش حنسيب
بلادنا ولا نغزل المقاومه ونسيبهم لحالهم
في البلد وربنا يهونها نعيش حرين
نستقل من هالوضع اللي احنا فيه لانه تعبنا
يعني على مدار السنين من يوم ما جينا على
غزه واحنا
مبهدلين يعني انا جيل 90 م لحقت اعمل شي
فجاه لقيت حالي شاب ابو 32 سنه 33 سنه خلص
بطلت ادور على مستقبلي صرت ادور على اودي
بيتي راح وسيارتي راحت ماضل عنا شي المال
معوض اهم شي اولادي بخير واولاد اخوي بخير
الحمد
لله
l